the Joe Rogan experience three
milliseconds you know it's not all about
zero to 60 I'm not Vin Diesel I don't
live my life one-quarter guess who else
is in Vin Diesel Vin Diesel yeah you
right you were a [ __ ] wear sunglasses
at night yeah he does yeah he does you
know he's gay he's quietly becoming a
billionaire from The Fast and Furious
franchise he owns it yeah so like yeah
it is
so like universal the rides not he's
quite becoming a billionaires probably
in a castle somewhere doing Caligula
[ __ ] and [ __ ] dudes live reason the
wife beater like barbecuing all the time
he's barbecuing
yeah and pacifiers you I do too but in a
beater if we're a wife beater my wife
yells at me I go shirtless rightfully so
if I have a wife beater on she'll stop
making fun of me that's it's so old
what's he doing but [ __ ] to be honest
okay I'm gonna show up with this with
Viral show Jodo drunk in love it's the
longest three minutes he made it himself
and we can't play this oh I had the song
we're gonna they can hear the but they
can hear those unnecessary just the
Dancing's on this but dude he's
celebrating like his movie went I don't
know platinum or some [ __ ] like that so
he does drunken love he doesn't cover if
him singing you do not like me one
quarter mile at a time if you're doing
this I'm on team the rock all day every
day
don't get along they hate each other
I heard rock was a big diva on set
chronic diva that's what I heard from
who people would you hear better on that
we're on the set just that you know the
rock sometimes shows up late and there's
trailers and he wanted the biggest
trailer and I'll sleep in diesel you
know he's mr. [ __ ] fast and furious
who knows who's right listen he just did
Beyonce cover so I don't know 16 rules
let's kill it fast enough yours have to
follow on set what there's rules certain
guys can't get hit a certain amount of
times they have to win fights and
certain ways you know the ronica true go
back to that that's not I'm just go back
to it go they have to go to Racing
School in Las Vegas that that makes
sense that knows the Fast and Furious
yeah
but you know the rocking of Vin Diesel
couldn't be on set at the same time they
hate each other so bad then just shoot
different scenes and like like shoot it
so it looked like someone was there they
hate each other so much didn't the rock
gotten a big thing with Tyrese - right
right I was just flipping out because
like all he has is fast and furious so
that when the rock did a spin off he's
like how dare you we're a family rock
like no we're not well enough dumbass
but remember when the rock was [ __ ]
on his music that was fantastic
well it cuz rock is so positive Tyrese
Gibson reignites fast feud with Dwayne
Johnson called spin-off hops and Charles
you went crazy
you went crazy on this all I've got and
yes Will Smith for money that's what
he's mad about
why dear ass Will Smith for money I
don't know if Ellen horizonte' sad yeah
the video here's the thing people lose
their mind man the actors really lose
their mind they work rate cuz you
pretend to be someone else all the time
yes the rock not good for you that guy
you know what he does just goes to the
gym the rock with two hours sleep a lot
of steroids
yeah I think Joe do you really you think
he's getting big like that from cocaine
again no I'm saying that John Jones they
but I'm just saying like anyone it mean
me and Brett cries were talking about
this think Brits can make a bit of it
but when you see the rock you know it is
working out two hours of sleep for sure
he's doing that stuff man he's grinding
he's on private jets he is loaded on
performance-enhancing drugs
his body is pulsing as your boy to go in
snitch would say with fun no
I don't know wrote jason statham and the
rock refused to lose fights against one
another Jason Statham come on bro
Jason settle down yeah how about you
both how about you really fight and then
that determines what happened yeah you
weigh a hundred and seventy pounds used
to be a limping swimmer you know that
he's a bad [ __ ] though Jason
Statham but the rock is an enormous
human well how are they the same height
there that doesn't make any sense that
is strange
is he on a box that doesn't make any
sense
okay ijou egocentric demands are nothing
new on how hope first of all we don't
know if this is true and this is the
Guardian which is kind of a nonsense
website so let's just stop right it's
interesting though and then you know
it's but it's also probably true behind
the movie series told the Wall Street
Journal paywall that actors including
Jason Statham Dwayne the rock Johnson
and Vin Diesel have contracts demanding
that limit the amount of punishment
their characters taking fights because
they don't want look like good you
imagine telling your agent that like I'm
down to do it BAM I wrote through the
script when he punches me in the face
I'm not going down bro I'm not doing it
you imagine doing that so crazy think of
you a group of friends were around you
like dude what the [ __ ] you doing what's
up Jason Diesel's sisters reported to
have been present on set asking for her
brother was going to get his licks back
in that could she been joking around my
sister might say that too if she saw me
in a movie get my ass kicked
[ __ ] him up we've been laughing together
I'd slap her in the face
get my legs back in wheel it's fake
[ __ ] talking about I'm also making a
hundred million dollars you'd whip my
ass every scene for that money
it's funny when a movie franchise just
gets bananas huge like that just so big
and Vin Diesel's like yeah cool man but
he's always doing a million things at
once
I have no easy or is he just doing fast
what else is he doing bro please go
television show were know yes he does
yeah like a game show Fear Factor type
television show he is always doing
something he's also doing Jumanji he did
a new Jumanji no time at the rock oh you
don't want the rock would you save Indy
Vin Diesel there were all he does it
Vindhyas goes I'm gonna fatten up this I
make a billion dollars sometimes even
you said Vin Diesel oh I'm sorry drunk
unless he's fixed on the rides at
Universal CityWalk is always doing a
million different things at once always
he's got ballers on HBO he's got that
that TV show that he does which is like
some crazy [ __ ] Fear Factor type deal
he's got Jumanji
he's always filming a million different
movies here's the thing do that again to
my point a lot of steroids a lot of
before ants and drugs and I'm all about
it
I'm no problem with this but let's tell
the kids like it is like I thought
Arnold was an I was like man hopefully
and get there one day if I keep being in
the gym I wish my dad like uh-huh it's
never happening not happening we got to
inject some [ __ ] in your ass
forgot to Vin Diesel's in the Avengers
what what he's Groot
he's the voice of the gallic site takes
him 30 minutes yeah I take some 30
minutes to do that